The last few months have seen remarkable progress
within the Regeneration East Area.
A new bmx track has been designed and built
by Olympian, Trent Jones, and construction
is nearly complete with final planting and
grass to be established
before it opens for use.
Directly opposite, the earthworks for the
sport fields are making good progress, and
we’ll soon be able to start on the softball
pitches and changing room facilities.
The storm water management area is also finished,
allowing the Honda forest planting to get underway.
The first community planting day was held
in late May with nearly 700 native trees and
shrubs dug into their new home.
The surrounding 3.2 hectares will gradually
be restored to lowland podocarp forest;
and interspersed with walking and cycling paths.
And this has all been made possible by the
support of the Honda Treefund.
This year we’re celebrating 30 years of
being in New Zealand and as part of that celebration,
we’re committed to planting 30,000 trees
in one year
and the Kaiapoi Regeneration project is part of that 30,000 trees.
We’re really thrilled to be part of it and
we hope our customers will come out and share
in the forest and help plant it.
Mayor David Ayers officially opened the Honda Forest
alongside Managing Director of Honda New Zealand, Nobuya Sonada.
He says it was pleasing to see former residents
of the area, taking part.
I hope they will come back here in future
years and say, "Well, my piece of land contributed
to something wonderful for Kaiapoi and Waimakariri
and for Canterbury."
And with over 14,000 trees yet to be planted,
there will be plenty more opportunities for
the community to take part in the restoration
of this area.